we had aggressive begging everywhere and
we had every day on average 60 or 70
serious felony crimes including robbery
stabbings 22 murders 1990 and that was
various serious crime as well as quality
of like crime so what did you do then to
clean up the subway it was very easy
it's exactly what the Transit Police now
in 2023 doing in New York once again and
surprise surprise the success they're
having is crime is going down and
quality life is improving we focus first
on fear evasion and fear of Asian was a
dollar fifteen theft of service the cops
did not want to enforce if they thought
they were just protecting the revenue of
the transit authority plus they would be
tied up anywhere from 12 to 24 hours
processing that fair evasion of rest we
structured it so that we put teams of
offices working together supervised and
we would arrest 10 or 15 or 20 Fair
vadas hold them together and then bring
them upstairs and we created what we
call the bust bus it was a specially
equipped bus where we could process the
prisoners right there at the station
seven out of 10 could be released
immediately because they had no record
so we could effectively give them desk
appearance tickets but three out of ten
were found to be wanted on warrants or
in many instances carrying weapons so
the figure we used back in 1990 was one
out of every 21 we arrested had some
type of weapon on them and one out of
every seven had a warrant outstanding
usually for a previous transdefense so
the beauty of what we were doing was the
public saw for the first time in 20
years the police were actively going
after the fair betas there's one line of
argument that is like well that's really
what was the Difference Maker here is
it's almost like it's it's less about
the public disorder perception of things
and more about you're kind of creating a
pretense or like almost like a fishing
expedition to be able to stop a bunch of
people and then from that you're able to
find the people that have outstanding
warrants and so forth and that is really
the part of it that's that's having an
effect more so than broken windows more
broadly understood is there anything to
that what you're describing is the term
is called a pre-text sop that stop that
you're trying to find a reason to make a
stop uh broken windows policing however
is about probable cause it's an offense
a criminal offense or a uh
administrative offense in the case of
the subway oftentimes that the police
officer actually sees the violation its
probable cause he has probable cause you
see him picking the pocket they see him
accosting the uh the other ride is on
the system so uh uh the the far left has
been able to really muddy the waters
significantly relative to trying to
equate broken windows policing which is
probable cause policing quality of life
leasing with stop question and frisk
both of them are essential tools of
American policing and need to be
practiced legally need to be supervised
closely and need to be defended
vigorously and I'm a staunch Defender
and proponent of both of them I think
how would you defend um stop question
and frisk because that seems to be the
even more controversial policy where
there's been you know real Constitution
additional questions and you know
rulings against it uh because you're
you're not actually you know as you said
you're not intervening after a crime
it's the co that's the police officer
kind of saying okay this we I believe
that this person is about to commit a
crime and doesn't that contribute
let me explain stop questioning Frisk is
protected uh and uh governed by Terry
versus Ohio Supreme Court case 1968 uh
we studied extensively when I was in the
police academy 1970 because it was so
new that you have to believe that a
crime has is or is about to be committed
and have to be able to articulate the
reasons for that and that articulation
is critical and what has happened in
recent years unfortunately because of
poor leadership poor supervision poor
training is offices are not trained
enough as to how to articulate why they
made the Stop and it's allowed in the
case of New York City where it was
overused well intended but overused in
the early 20th century could you give me
an example just a concrete example of
when it what is a good use of stopping
foreskin what is a bad use of stop and
stop question and frisk
well it basically goes right to the
heart of reasonable suspicion you have
to be able to articulate why are you
making the Stop and in city after City
around the country it's been determined
that many of those stops are being made
inappropriately so it's given stop
question and frisk oftentimes it's
called stop and frisk but the important
part of stop question Frisk is the
question you stop somebody you have the
legal aid to stop them if you have
reasonable sufficient that you can
document but then you question and then
the questioning basically made lead to
effectively the Frisk the fear that the
individual may be on so it's an
essential tool of policing some cities
of Christ claim that they don't do it
you cannot please any community in
America without the office of having the
ability to do a stock question Frisk
it's like going into a doctor's office
and the doctor's not allowed to ask you
any questions about why you're there one
point that our colleague CJ sirmella
highlighted here was that uh in that
essay Kelling said that broken windows
policing is a highly discretionary set
of activities that seeks the least
intrusive means of solving a problem
whether it's prostitution drug dealing
in a park graffiti uh public drunkenness
and moreover depending on the problem
good broken windows policing seeks
Partners to address it social workers
city code enforcers business Improvement
District staff teachers medical
personnel clergy and others do you agree
with kelling's argument there or you
know clarification about broken windows
that it's there's more to it than the
police need to be out there aggressively
enforcing a reinfection
that's correct he has never basically
indicated nor have I that you have to
enforce with the rest every infraction
but you do have to address the
infraction the broken windows is never
going to work with just police
enforcement it has to work with what did
Kylie and Gunn do in the transit
authority even as we were arresting Fair
evadas uh seven out of 10 of them were
stopped but then they were released with
a ticket they were in jail they were
inconvenienced for a half an hour or so
but they are simultaneously cleaning up
the subway they were getting rid of the
trash they were getting rid of the
graffiti they were improving getting rid
of the on 6 000 train cars they got rid
of that graffiti that was like the
Hallmark of New York of the 70s and 80s
and so it is with a partnership with the
station masters with the transit
authority with the police there's an
exit prime example the business
Improvement districts in New York that
are so successful against uh Central
Park uh by Empire why are they so
successful they focus on on cleanliness
they focus on enforcement and they focus
on furniture the idea of benches and
street lights the creative idea in
Bryant Park of not having permanent
benches but cheers because you can move
around so three or four you want to sit
together you get a little folding chair
and you make your own little group you
want to sit by yourself take that chair
and go sit off in the corner and it's
that creative thinking that is at what
broken windows was all about with the
dotted line on the top is the
incarceration rate in the U.S the bottom
is New York City during the relevant
time period and you see the Divergence
there it actually goes down in New York
city so it's not every year every year
yes so it's it's not like you know just
locking up all the criminals or
something made New York safer and New
York during that time period saw greater
cry improvements in reducing crime than
the rest of the nation so
um that that's an interesting aspect uh
to to note of your approaches that did
not require mass incarceration some of
what resulted with that lower crime Etc
was increased tourism increased jobs to
support that tourism the number it had
not been a new hotel opened in New York
uh when Giuliani came in in 94 for years
and then he started having all these
boutique hotels popping up I think there
were like 65 of those basically a couple
years and I remember going with Giuliani
and 94 down to the South Side Seaport
International uh meeting of Real Estate
Investors and telling them Point Blank
you want to start taking a close look at
putting your money to New York City
because we're going to make it safe and
we did and uh it continues to be a
relatively safe City compared to some of
what's going on in America hey that's an
excerpt from our reason live stream with
Bill Bratton who was New York City's top
cop he also worked in LA and oversaw
dramatic decreases in crime we talked
about what's going on now what worked in
the past what might work in the future
and how do you square all of that with
the need for civil liberties if you want
to watch the whole video check it out
and if you want to check out our recent
live streams we do them every Thursday
at Zach weismiller and I at 1 pm eastern
time go to reason.com and check us out